now let's get to our first guest he put
the jack in will and grace and he also
co-hosts the number one comedy podcast
in the world smartless his new podcast
is called hypochondriactor which was
awesome
please welcome sean hayes
[Applause]
[Applause]
i like that i have more to go
[Music]
that is oh you win for best interest
thank you her interest yeah
look at how gorgeous oh i got nothing i
showed up
in in my pjs and my team got a hold of
me like harry potter
do you want me to help you tie that no i
had it tied and i felt like i was
gonna die too yeah i don't know how you
all do that two steps
yeah um it's nice to have you here in
person it's so nice to see you how about
you have a show
i know anything it's doing really well
this is a long way from when
we first were hanging at hollywood game
night i think the first time i did it
yeah
you were so nice to me in that show very
competitive sorry i love it
and kelly was so nice to do i produced a
show called hollywood game night and you
were honest
i've done it twice i love it um but
how's your puppy is he still chewing
puppy yes
yes my puppy is chewing everything his
name is ricky he's a golden doodle we
call his mouth the chamber of secrets
oh look at it wait a minute yes because
i have henry a gold digger that's black
right yeah so right i remember this yeah
and that
is nothing how he is now he's like
a gigantic horse you could put a saddle
on and ride down the 101.
he look at how big he is did they tell
oh my god
isn't that crazy and he still thinks
he's this big
i'm telling you what golden doodle look
at that face movies should be made
because of this space you're talking
about the dog yes unfortunately
yeah because it ain't happening for the
other one
no it's just i look at that little oh
golden doodles your little eyes i love
it i saw something though it's a video
i think we have it you're sneezing and
you scared the crap out of your dog i
want to show it
yeah yeah yeah oh my god that's right
come on sorry sorry that came out
it was like a combination of broken
glass
a scream and stepping on his foot
oh my goodness i love that your dog was
like which orifice did that come from
your body because i guess that's what my
teeth your teeth would sound like very
happy no but yeah that was crazy
a sneeze like that has never come out of
me if i had no idea why or how
i sneeze so loud you do i mean is that
shocking
did i'd do something loud no no that's
hilarious not shocking
um no my poor dog henry he's just like
calm down
is he as big as ricky here's the thing
did they lie to you because like
i was told it was gonna be 15 to 18
pounds like 45 pounds later
not 15 to 18 pounds which actually i
like big dogs so i'm fine with it that
is
kind of like how my weight went before
and after kovitch
right because they were like i don't
think you look great because i don't
gain 20 pounds yeah oh my gosh i keep
writing these people that lost my i'm
like what's happening
i swear to god i like two months ago i
was like joke's over i have
got to lose i mean no i say that but i
don't follow through
sean everyone says it right right but
you don't you know follow through well
some people do apparently
um but i have to ask you this because
joe biden is now president and
i heard him say i know it's exciting um
but
i thought it was still out i thought
there was no conceding
no no no i was there in the office with
him
okay great yeah oh that's right i was
and he did say that will and grace
did more than anything else to shift
like how people viewed gay marriage
yeah and i never really thought about
that but i think that's absolutely true
especially reaching on a broad
scale like so many you're in the homes
of you know all across america
i mean look i got the when i got the
pilot which is the first episode
i was 27 years old yeah so just a couple
years ago
but i um thanks that took just a second
but um no and i was just happy to get a
job on a tv show i had no idea that the
byproduct would be something that was
bigger than all of us
and then i'm sitting at home on the
couch one day i don't remember this is
when joe biden was the vice president
and he said something on uh msnbc or i
don't know some show
and he was like will and grace did more
to educate america about the gay
movement than anything and i was like
what
like i think i'm sure though art does
inspire like
real life like i think i'm a real life
inspires art i guess chicken yeah but
but yeah i i think it's absolutely true
i just never thought about it also it's
the power of comedy
it's the power of comedy is is the
ability to educate
people without them knowing it because
if they're enjoying you
there's no you can't yeah you can't
combat that
right i agree right his new podcast is
called
hypochondriactor which is genius he
hosts it with a talented and funny
doctor who is joining us now
she's a double board certified physician
specializing in
internal medicine and obesity medicine
everybody say hello to dr priyanka wally
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um it's so funny when we have more than
one guest and we're like
what's up what's gonna say even one more
it will be in the parking lot i know
we've had it and i'm usually over here
and it's wrapped around it's funny
um how did you two meet so do you want
to do you know you go you go
well okay so i met with hazy mills
productions which
um runs the podcast and they pitched
this idea about
wanting to do a medical podcast that's
funny and entertaining
yeah and you know i practiced medicine
but i was also
doing stand-up comedy for all these
years which i'm gonna get to in a minute
yeah right just let me interrupt
she's this gorgeous indian female
stand-up comedian
practicing board certified doctor i'm
upset i mean all those things
you've got all the cards explore that
game all the cards please explore it
away
i'm an open book no that's awesome
though stand up it was so interesting
that you also did that
yeah totally but the reason i decided to
to do the gig is
basically because you know there's a lot
of medical information out there
a lot of fake news and i figure if we're
going to educate the public
you know i want to be involved in this
so all of the medical stuff that we talk
about on the show
actually i fact check and i make sure
we're not doing any fake news because
lord knows it's hard it's so important
because it's hard to sift through
all the bs sometimes yeah yeah so tell
us about the new podcast so you
you talk about real things but it's also
in a funny way yeah so i
i've kind of been obsessed with medical
stories always my favorite part of like
a lot of talk shows is when people
uh in the public eye come on and share a
story hopefully that's funny and
everything all worked out those are my
favorite kind of stories
and uh and and because of that like if
if i read or hear of
an issue a medical issue i think i i'm
gonna have it if i haven't had it like
even when kovid started i'm walking down
the street i'm like did i just get it
from that guy
like we i feel like that all the time
yeah and so i'm a self-diagnosed
hypochondriac
but um and i just added actor on the end
hypochondriactor
and uh and that's and then we met we're
like why don't we just do this podcast
that's
fun and entertaining and informative and
it connects people in case you think
you might have something it just helps
to hear other people talk about it
and if you think you have something
probably you'll be able to be like it's
probably not that you might be over you
know i'm saying
exactly yeah which is probably what you
say a lot to him yeah all the time a lot
of reassurances
yeah which is fine i love that right but
what i love about the podcast as well is
like we're talking about everyday
ailments right like things like diabetes
or anxiety and depression
but we're also exploring it from a very
non-traditional angle like we do this
episode with kristen bell where she
talks about
her history of depression and how she
uses psychedelic mushrooms to work
through that
wow which i never knew and then very
fast times at ridgemont high
yeah different purpose but yeah yeah
a lot of people don't know that there's
research out there with psychedelic
mushrooms and
mental health issues you know um well to
you dr wally sean jokes about his
hypochondria like
but it's real so um how do you how do
you deal with that as a doctor
because you don't want to tell people
you know you're insane
you don't have that i don't know i don't
do that right so
um look my kind of philosophy or the way
i approach medicine is
whatever someone's experiencing they
know their body
even though i've studied the books and
i've done the years
you know your body better than anyone
else because you're the one living in it
yeah and so when someone's coming in and
saying hey i'm experiencing this pain or
i'm feeling this anxiety
it's real to them i love that and that's
what you taught me too it's real to the
person
and so i as a physician have to believe
the patient and i do
so whether someone has hypochondria i
mean i approach it with curiosity
like okay what is this person really
experiencing that's causing them to
have this moment where they're feeling
all these things
right i always say and you can do this
or not do this we don't have to
but just name a part of the body inside
or out and i will have a true story
about it on me well let's try something
then okay
okay sure i'm gonna name a body part
sure and you tell us what's
wrong or was wrong at some point yeah
okay ready okay
name literally anything yeah i will have
a star
okay right nostril right now you can see
it
you see this right here wait what's
wrong do you see how the there's extra
skin right there
what am i right nostril do you see no so
it's not like oh
it is turned out guys like turn over so
i have uh the camera get back
in the world with notice yeah right so i
had a deviated septum and i went into
this doctor
um it's actually in the first episode of
hypochondriactor i talked about this
so i went in to get uh the deviated
septum fix and i said while you're down
there i have a bump on my left hand
on the left side of my nose do you mind
getting a twofer and you know
doing double d's like salivating yeah of
course i can get it so i did it a week
later two weeks later whatever you take
the packing out right
yeah and he had this little fetish of
like cleaning out the stuff in my nose
like the
you have to go back and get all the
stuff cleaned out like the the
mucus the dried mucus and the blood that
gets stuck in there so here's this
little
tool and he's like he's getting it out
and he went bam and it's like i hit an
artery and all this blood came out
and i freaked out of course yeah right
and he's like calm down calm down you
need to calm your heart down i'm like
you know right it's not your blood it's
my blood
because i get the e already and i was
like my heart race is faster than more
blood coming it was all over it was
crazy
but good thing i'm here and everything
and they cauterized it and it's fine
you do bleed a lot from your head i've
had an injury in my head as well right
here
late at night and i bent down i was just
putting something down and i hit
something really sharp
i bled so much for my head i was sure i
was gonna die
oh my god okay big toe anything wrong
with your big toe big toe right now
well i have plantar fasciitis i do too
you do oh my god we can't
so um
we're almost there we're almost there
according to the biden administration
we're almost there
close so uh no i it sucks it hurts yeah
it
hurts really bad and so now it's creeped
into the just the ball of my foot on my
right side i don't know why so i have a
little pad in there right now
i wear i'm i am jell-in as well oh you
are
sure isn't it like you know i wear
things too mine is because i performed
like for a decade barefoot and i got all
these like problems with my friends
but you know it was worth it i had fun
all right so anyway i love this podcast
i think it's brilliant i think what you
said is
that's most important is yes it's funny
but it is really important
that people can go somewhere and get
real knowledge that you can trust and
believe in and check out you know
absolutely yeah that's really and i
think it's hilarious that you also did
stand up
oh thanks while doing this isn't that
great oh thank you
it's just like where is all the time
that you did that okay
but anyway shawn's podcast smartless and
hypochondriactor are available anywhere
you get your podcast
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure